digamos que tenemos un poco de cloruro
de sodio sólido un poco de sal de mesa
eso de ahí pretende ser nuestra pila de
sal colocaremos nuestra sal en un poco
de agua en un vaso de precipitado que
contiene h2o el cloruro de sodio se va a
disolver en el agua el cloruro de sodio
es nuestro su luto y el agua será
nuestro
del té
este es el proceso de disolución y si
ves más detenidamente el cloruro de
sodio el cloruro de sodio sólido es un
cristal iónico y entonces se mantiene
unido por los enlaces iónicos el catión
de sodio con una carga positiva es
atraído a la unión cloruro con una carga
negativa y entonces eso mantiene unido a
nuestro cristal iónico cuando pones el
cloruro de sodio sólido en agua recuerda
que el agua es una molécula pola el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno
el oxígeno obtiene una carga parcial
negativa y estos hidrógenos obtienen una
carga parcial positiva así que tenemos
una molécula
y claro aquí y la carga negativa en el
oxígeno va a interactuar con la carga
positiva del sodio las cargas opuestas
se atraen así que tenemos una molécula
de agua aquí atraída a este canción de
sodio y esta molécula de agua hará lo
mismo
carga parcial negativa atraída a la
carga positiva en el sodio
y entonces las moléculas de agua van a
separar los cationes del sodio y
eventualmente se dará esta situación de
aquí tenemos los oxígenos parcialmente
negativos
estos van a interactuar con el camión
del sodio
el agua es un dipolo y el camión de
sodio es unión por lo que podemos llamar
la interacción un dipolo y entonces las
moléculas de agua rompen los enlaces
iónicos separan al camión de sodio lo
rodean y llamamos a este proceso de
hidratación este es el proceso de
drá
si yo
donde el guión está rodeado y
estabilizado por una capa de nuestras
moléculas de solvente y lo mismo
sucederá con el año oruro el año en
cloruro de aquí arriba está cargado
negativamente pero esta vez la carga
negativa será atraída a la parte
positiva de nuestra molécula polar el
oxígeno es parcialmente negativo y este
hidrógeno será parcialmente positivo y
entonces cargas opuestas se atraen la
carga positiva va a interactuar con la
carga negativa lo mismo pasa con esta
molécula de agua tenemos un hidrógeno
parcialmente positivo y nuevamente esta
interacción va a separar a ese año
cloruro y lo moverá a la solución por lo
que tenemos hidrógenos parcial 20
positivos
interactuando con nuestros uniones de
cloruro cargados negativamente
nuevamente tenemos interacción jon de
polvo y elaño en cloruro está rodeado
por nuestras moléculas de agua así que
nuevamente tenemos un proceso de
hidratación el resultado final es que
cada canción de sodio está rodeado por
moléculas de agua y cada año en cloruro
está rodeado por moléculas de agua por
lo que el cloruro de sodio se ha
disuelto en agua
formamos una solución una solución
líquida de cloruro de sodio y la manera
en la que verás escrito eso es
cloruro de sodio sólido que será
agregado
el agua nuestro solvente y las moléculas
de agua rodearán a nuestros iones ahora
tenemos iones de sodio en solución
escribiremos
aquí
por jon de sodio a coso y tenemos iones
de cloruro
también en solución escribimos también a
cu aquí tenemos una solución acuosa de
cloruro de sodio el cloruro de sodio se
ha disuelto en agua también tenemos un
vaso de precipitado que contiene una
solución de enea
el una solución acuosa de nhl tiene
cationes de sodio en solución y iones de
cloruro en solución digamos que tenemos
otro vaso de precipitado que contiene
una solución de nitrato de plata
ag no3 una solución acuosa de nitrato de
plata significa que tenemos cationes de
plata en solución a gemas y iones de
nitrato n
3 -
y ahora digamos que añadimos el
contenido de uno de los vasos de
precipitado al otro agregamos el
contenido de digamos este vaso
a este vaso
estás combinando nuestras dos soluciones
notaremos algunas cosas notaremos que el
volumen incrementa obviamente ya que
estamos vaciando el contenido de uno en
el otro y también veremos un poco de
formación de un sólido un poco de
sólidos se formará aquí
y ese se forma cuando los cationes de
plata
interactúan con los cañones de cloruro
obtenemos un sólido formando ese cloruro
de plata ag se es que veremos aquí ag
l y ponemos un subíndice s indicando la
formación de un sólido este sólido es
conocido como precipitado y este sólido
de manera espontánea aparece en la
solución este es el proceso de
precipitación que es el opuesto de
disolución en la disolución ponemos un
sólido en agua y formamos añón es en la
precipitación los guiones se juntan para
formar un sólido y ese sólido
espontáneamente se forma en la solución
así que el cloruro de plata es nuestro
precipitado aún tendremos algunos iones
en solución aún tenemos cationes de
sodio
uniones de nitrato
aquí adentro tendremos camiones de sodio
en solución y cañones de nitrato en
solución
podríamos sumarlos aquí podríamos decir
n a n
acuoso lo que significa que esos guiones
están presentes en la solución veamos
más a detalle lo que está pasando con la
formación del precipitado sabemos que
tenemos cationes de plata
en solución aquí está nuestra ocasión de
plata y sabemos que este guión está
rodeado por moléculas de agua en el
proceso de hidratación estos oxígenos
son parcialmente negativos y ya que los
opuestos se atraen hay una fuerza que
está deteniendo a este guión en nuestra
solución cierto las fuerzas de
hidratación lo mismo pasa con el año
cloruro
la carga parcial positiva en el
hidrógeno las cargas opuestas se atraen
y entonces esas moléculas de agua
estabilizan este año en cloruro en
solución cuando juntamos esas dos
soluciones formamos nuestro precipitado
formamos cloruro de plata formamos este
cristal iónico de aquí y nuevamente
cargas opuestas se atraen por lo que el
camión de plata con carga positiva es
atraído a la unión
cargado negativamente aquí ya que
notamos que esté sólido se formó la
atracción electroestática de nuestro
cristal iónico deberá de ser mayor que
las fuerzas de hidratación este año el
cloruro se moverá a acá y luego este
camión de plata se moverá para acá así
que los iones salieron de la solución y
un precipitado se formó espontáneamente
se formó nuestro cloruro de plata sólido
esta es una manera de representar lo que
está pasando aquí pudimos también haber
quitado todos los iones en lugar de
escribir eso otra manera de representar
lo que sucede sería decir que la
solución de cloruro de sodio
acciones de sodio en solución escribimos
nuestros cationes de sodio aquí en iones
de cloruro cl - le agregamos a eso
nuestra solución de nitrato de plata
tiene iones
en solución a gemas y uniones de nitrato
n o 3 - y vimos que se formó un
precipitado
formamos a g
que es nuestro sólido escribimos a jesé
el que es nuestro precipitado y luego
también tuvimos canciones de sodio y
acciones de nitrato tenemos canciones de
sodio n a más y tuvimos acciones de
nitrato n
3 -
hemos escrito bastante cualquiera de las
dos te dan la misma cantidad de
información pero esta de aquí abajo te
muestra a todos los aviones y realmente
sólo algunos de los iones están
reaccionando el camión de plata y el año
cloruro se juntan para formar cloruro de
plata podemos escribir una ecuación
iónica neta mostrando lo que pasa para
formar nuestro precipitado podemos
mostrar nuestros cationes de plata aquí
qué más podemos mostrar nuestros
cationes de plata y nuestros ángeles de
fluoruro combinándose para formar
nuestro precipitado
ag se l
esta es la
cúa
acción
yo
me da
y esta es la ecuación iónica neta porque
algunos de nuestros iones no están
tomando parte en esta reacción solo
están observando lo que pasa el camión
de sodio que está del lado izquierdo
está también del lado derecho es un
guión en solución y lo mismo pasa con el
año el nitrato está del lado izquierdo
como un guión en solución y está del
lado derecho como unión en solución
el camión de sodio y el año nitrato son
llamados iones espectadores esto se
llama iones
porque no están participando en lo que
está sucediendo solo están observando
como el cloruro de plata se precipita de
la solución eso es a lo que llamamos
iones espectadores este es el concepto
de precipitación